[Musique]
info ou intox ce soir avec anthony st
léger anthony bonsoir à tous voir venir
avec sur cette journaliste russe son
geste a fait le tour du monde dans cette
journaliste qui a brandi en plein jt à
la télévision une pancarte pour dire non
à la guerre elle a été libérée a écopé
d'une simple amende depuis son geste les
comptes à son nom sur les réseaux
sociaux pullulent en marina aux yannick
aubin noms synonymes de cours à agen
depuis hier elle est devenue d'ailleurs
rapidement une héroïne sur les réseaux
sociaux et depuis son irruption hier en
plein direct et bien la photo de son
profil facebook vous voyez cumule plus
de 129 me like cette photo où elle
arbore vous voyez ce collier à la faute
de l'ukraine or et bleu puisque c'est
son père qui est ukrainien et puis rouge
bleu et blanc comme la russie puisque sa
mère est russe et un compte twitter à
son nom aussi rapidement cumulé à les
likes et celui ci un conte qui
expliquait dans différents tweets dans
deux en l'occurrence qu'ils ne
regrettaient pas ce qu'il avait fait le
profil et qui demandait le soutien à des
internautes mais ce compte a été
supprimé depuis et plus précisément
depuis la publication de ce deuxième
tweet un faux comptes créés en fait la
semaine dernière effectivement rien à
voir donc avec la réalité il officiait
jusqu'ici sous le pseudo juan arrêt dans
le dos et scarlett dondo pardon c'est ce
que nous apprend cette place cette
plateforme qui analyse elle est donnée
sur twitter au juana redondo et bien du
nom du journaliste colombo américain qui
a été blessés à irbine dimanche donc en
ukraine après une attaque russe alors
compte qu'il n'a pourtant rien à voir
avec lui plusieurs comptes ont vu le
jour comme celui-ci qui ont également
été suspendus tout comme des profils
instagram vous en avez un exemple ici et
d'ailleurs si vous vous trompez si vous
tapez le nom de marie a osé nico va dans
la barre de recherche vous en avez toute
une flopée tout ceci faut il est vrai
que les hommes que les autres des
comptes qui pour certains vous renvoyez
sept cas de celui ci vers fausse
cagnotte pour soi disant aidez la
journaliste qui était jugé aujourd'hui
et ces arnaques elles ne sont pas vous
avez par exemple une idée de cagnotte
ici vous voyez que 0 euros ont été
collectés alors ces arnaques elles ne
sont pas sans rappeler celle dont je
vous parlais il ya quelques temps et qui
sont en vigueur depuis le début de la
guerre celle sur tik tok avec ses faux
direct ces fausses images et donc c'est
faux appels aux dons un journaliste
italien de fact checking c'est lui
lancer dans cette lourde tâche que de
débusquer les faux comptes de la
journaliste en question on en fait tout
un tout un fred sur twitter alors plus
généralement comment dissocier les vrais
des fausse image de profil et donc les
faux profils et bien vous trouverez
quelques clés dans cet épisode d'infos
intox sur le site des observateurs de
france 24 évidemment la présence de
combattants tchétchènes aux côtés des
troupes russes en ukraine notamment sont
emmenés par le président ramzan kadirov
alimente les rumeurs en faisant
ressurgir des images du passé a
effectivement des publications
essentiellement en anglais qui montrent
ces images d'archivés on va les
découvrir ensemble elles datent de
1999 on va voir donc cet homme ce sont
ces deux femmes qui sont face à des
soldats l'homme récit des sourates du
courant les soldats lui demande
d'arrêter ce qu'il ne fait pas est l'un
des soldats va tirer sur lui à bout
portant une exécution sommaire et le
soldat ensuite sourire aux lèvres qui va
déclarer qu'il s'agit d'une opération
antiterroriste c'est comme ça que ça se
passe ici dit il les légendes comme ce
tweet que l'on va voir qui explique
qu'ils accompagnent les publications
affirmant qu'il s'agit de l'armée
ukrainienne de l'époque et d'ajouter et
bien qu'elle exécute un homme tchétchène
donc lors de la seconde guerre de
tchétchénie une référence au passé pour
justifier toujours selon ces internautes
que la tchétchénie combattent
actuellement autres aux côtés de la
russie il prendrait donc aujourd'hui
leur revanche sur le passé contre les
ukrainiens de l'époque
rien à voir non c'est tout est faux
c'est un raccourci montée de toutes
pièces un la recherche d'image inversée
elle nous aiguille
nous ramène sur plusieurs occurrences
qui viennent depuis huit ans environ
depuis 2014 et les cinéphiles auront
d'ailleurs peut être repéré la
supercherie pourquoi parce que cet
extrait il provient en fait de ce film
deux soeurs du français michel
hazanavicius qui évoque bien cette
deuxième guerre en tchétchénie en 1999
il y est question de 2,4 destin qui vont
se croiser films sortis en 2014 alors
france 24 juin l'acteur qui est à
l'origine de cette exécution sommaire
dans le film évidemment maxim's épisode
ni pardon pour la prononciation il est
ukrainien il s'indigne justement de
cette désinformation dont il a eu
connaissance
et il nous explique qu'il voudra plus
tard répondre un peu plus longuement à
france24 quand il en aura plus le temps
évidemment à la guerre en ukraine le
retenant évidemment alors ce
détournement ce n'est pas une première
puisque déjà en 2015 cela avait même
donné lieu à une chasse à l'homme contre
lui contre l'acteur en question capture
d'écran du visage de maxim a piece of me
à l'appui c'est d'ailleurs ce qui
expliquait dans être publications
facebook à l'époque l'un de ses amis
merci beaucoup anthony st léger pour
cette chronique qu'on peut retrouver
bien sûr sur notre site internet
www.francebillet.com nous on se retrouve
dans quelques instants paris direct
continue rester avec nous